>>> AND WE'RE PACKAC
TH ONGOINGIGT, RAINE.COIL O19G T
NI AAWR AND IN THE BATTLE IN
BAKHMUT.>> Reporter: IT WAS HAR
TH FOR BAKHMUTS RM STILL
RAINE MONDAY SAID IT HAD
PU FORCE
AND RUSSIN NG.TIONS. FLL DAYSAY
E SAID ABANDON.
THERE WAGUYINGE REEDS, HSAYEIN
GUME FOR THREE
AND OUT OF THE CITY, NEWS OF THS
AG U.SNDFIRE
T
UKRAS FIGHT.
THGSAD AOTF NTED TO T
SOOPER
G  TO DRIV E.
DON'TIEVEF,
ED DO SOMETHING
.
>> LET'SSTORY.
S NEAR THE F
ANDY HASJANUARY ASFOREIGN GI  A
T D FROM BAKHMUTAS THE FIGHTINGS
HIS THD THE LAST
TIME THEY OKE.
ASKED COOPER IS THERERY AND GEE
CAN YOSEE HOT SAUCCK I THOUSAND
SHOWING WHAT IHEMERGED
NETWORKERACESO COVER.BUT SOON .
THEY ARE ALL MIRACULOUSLY OKAY,
BUATTACK HAS STARTED.
WATCH AND YOU E A RUSSPROACH AN
METERS FROM
SHELLS L
MINUTES.CK PERSISTS FOOV
D ON.HE BR FIGHT FOR BAKUT
>> SO S HAPPENING AROUND
BAKHMUT A MATTER OF WEEKS AGO,
E RUSSIANS SEEM TO BE
SIGNALING THAT TY  IN THE
ASCENDANT SKPRS E IAN HEF E RUN
ARTILLERY
TO PULL BACK.
THE FRONT FOOT AND RUSSIANS ARE
ABANDONING THEIR PIT.
THE CITY'S BECOMING A KIND OGNAO
PROJECT STS FORCES IN.
OF LIFE.ITE THE EXY LOSS
ONCAONITY COUNCI
SPOKESPERSONEY MIGAVE LOST 100,
MO LIKELY NOT AROUND
30,000 FOOEWATLANTICUKE A
APPLEBAUST E CASE FOR THE TOT
LIONUKRAINYOU WRITE THAT
BE EASFINED.
IT WOULD MEAN SORE
SAFETY, JUSTICE BUGESOWITH ZELE.
WHERE DOES HISIMISOUT A  ABOUT I
T
IM PART
R TIHE ENTE
UKRA
I MEANOWBAKHMUT, RUSSIA BOGGED
TO RELATIVELY SMALL MO
MONTHS.
IF YOUK 14, 15
MONTHS UKRAINE
WAG TO BE OUT, WIPED
OFF THE IN MATTER OF DAYS,
AND YOKNERE IN--S IN KYIV LAST .
THE CHARS MALE GHT'R PERIODIC
NOW,HE
ANYMORE MEA ALL OF THAT
OU C IDER ESTIMATED CAPABIDESIRL
CA THIS WITHOUT FOREWITHOUS. IS
E WEAPYSTEMS
ADVANCEWEAPON EMS.
THIS IS TH
>> MORE TH FAR.
HAVE JUST A OR
HELP, AND A LITT BIT MORTRIO HEH
BATTLEFIELD>> YOU ALSO WRITE A.
E UKIATING
FOR THE COUNTEROFFENSIVE
WEST
COROBE AND OTHS THE WORLD WHOSE
E OPSS AUT
THE STATES. YOU TFO
AGH TH?
THAT VERY MUCH.
I THINK HE PRETTY ACUTTANDIN TH.
THE S.LEADER.
TO UT ARCH
BUT NOAI IE ORUKRAINE CAN KEEP N
HA US IN
STEARAINE OTHO100%.'S A RANGE
INSIDE THE BIDEN ON.
I THINK EVYONE'S HEART,
CENLIDENT'S HEAR
UKPRESIDENT OFAINE.
E ARE EWABE
UKRAIN CY SH
RUSS OF AL
TERRITORY THAT IG. RIGHT, CRIME
CRIE HARDES
THERE'S OBVIOUSL
HER THEY CANEAR, THIHAT TI
INS
NE
>> PRESIDENT BIDN I
INTERVIEWED HIM LAST FALL SEEMED
ATELLFWAERF Y, BUT THE INTEREST
WORKSHOPS.
YOU SAW HOW DRONES USEFORAPHY H
TRANSFORMED INTO LL WEAPONS THA.
INGENUITY OF THE
UKIA
?
>> THIHY THEY DON'T NEED OOPS FH
NEED THATH ADVICE
.D MATE
THESE DRS E
AMAZING.
THE NSE MISTF
AT WASFASCINATING.
HE SAID THE WAR STD, PEOPLE
THOUGHT
A LARGE SOVIE
UNDERSTANIS
THE LAST YNOWERARMYINNOVATIVE.
THRE STILLNSREHTING LIKE
AMERICAN S FORDRS ARSE
THE BAKHMUD ELSE
WHERE  TRYING
ALIVE, TY CARE, E E UKRAINIANS T
THEY'RE USING
DRONES.
THEY'RE USING MODEL AIRPLANES AS
ES.
AND THEY'RE DOTH
ENT ONIT'S T